[MUSIC]
I'm an engineer by my
undergraduate education and
an engineer by my postgraduate
education as well.
One thing led to the other and commercial
real estate popped up, I was appointed
as the global Chief Information Officer
in early March of 2020.
I have to say that my leadership
through this journey of the company and
the people in the company have benefited
greatly from my experience at SEP.
The connection points that one
would build from the program, and
how long lasting that will be,
and how that would transpire into
meaningful things that either clusters
of us, or all of us would do.
The 2019 SEP group had got together and
talked about building a fund that would
help entrepreneurs with much needed
capital in areas that we thought we
believed in, as a collective group.
I am very proud to say that that idea has
transformed into a company our focus is
really around investments that conformed
to the principles of the Stanford slogan,
change lives change
organizations change the world.
[MUSIC]